but this is why we're excited this is
why Oprah's here as much as she loves
talking the table she's here for a very
special reason yes only on CBS this
morning she's revealing her highly
anticipated highly club selection Oprah
so would you pick it's called the water
dancer by Tana hasi coats and I know the
world has been waiting for this novel
and Tana has e-coat certainly didn't
need me to choose the novel to give it
attention but it is it is one of the
best books I've ever read in my entire
life whoa
that's a good reason for thinking in the
top five here's a background the water
dancer tells the story of a young man
born into bondage on a plantation who
was gifted with a mysterious power
it is coates first novel and follows his
acclaimed nonfiction work his moving
autobiography between the world and me
won the 2015 National Book Award and his
landmark essay that case for reparations
push the discussion about payments to
the descendants of slave onto the
national stage guess who else is joining
us at the table Tana Jose which guys
this is the first time they've met I did
Tana hotsy congratulations to you thank
you so your meeting for the first time
what was your reaction when you heard
the news for the first time that you
were gonna be this pick well if I'm
honest about it I had some heads up like
I got this text that said there's a call
coming at 10 a.m. this morning you have
to be available after this call it was
my editor panicked at and but the phone
call I mean it was a tremendous it's a
tremendous tremendous honor I mean you
know you're going into the company of
people like Toni Morrison yeah wholesome
white you know and so this was like a
huge huge you know honor for me but why
did it affect you so over I remember Lee
Hebert who's our book editor at the
magazine said you know that Oprah just
called town AHA see and she was crying
on the telephone I hadn't read the book
yet she was crying on the telephone
why what was it about the well I've
always been a student of our history of
african-american history and you know I
grew up reciting Sojourner truths and I
a woman before I even knew what I was
really saying and I always recognize
I've been carried by the ancestor
and Tana Hasse's book the water dancer
allows us to see that but also to
experience and feel what that carriage
has been like and I was so moved by
there's there's something on if you get
the hardcover Edition on page 110 where
he actually describes what slavery is he
says slavery is everyday longing is
being born into a world forbidden [ __ ]
holes and tantalizing Untouchables to
land around you but close you him the
biscuits you bake you bury the longing
because you know where it must lead see
this is your your first novel I mean
it's nothing you've you've done a lot of
writing before but a novel is a
different kind of things and and I know
you spent you spent ten years
researching this researching and writing
it's deceptive because actually I
started writing this before I started
writing my second book between the world
and me before I you know case for
reparations we were eight years I
actually started this before so while
this comes out publicly later than some
of the work that you know I became a
problem before actually been working on
this for a long time has been in your
heart for a long time and on the page in
various really terrible versions that
the public should never see you told you
told them before you sent a version to
Michael shaven and he said what this is
not fiction what did you think I sent it
to him to get that note I mean I would
to be honest with you that was no
different than the process I go through
for nonfiction between the world to me I
had a very similar interaction with my
editor Chris Jackson so that that that
was not you know I mean that's writing
if you're really in there and you're
blessed with you know friends and
colleagues who are going to be honest
with you that that's sort of thing I
suppose that you wanted to capture what
I thought you did so well to capture the
emotion of slavery and the intelligence
of the slaves yeah that's something that
we never hear about read about ya know I
think you know in the course of my
research you know I think in the common
mind people just think of you know
enslaved people as these sort of
and picking machines but I don't don't
think we realized the extent to which
their labor was dependent upon and not
just manual you know mental I mean one
of the things that you know we talked
about I think we've got big ideas in
this book but this is a pleasure to read
it's yeah fly you know you're not only
writing essays you also wrote Black
Panthers would you bring you mix fiction
also with with real-life characters like
Harriet Tubman is a character how did
you decide to do that well you know I'm
from Baltimore and Baltimore's in barrel
area Thomas from Maryland my family's
from Eastern Shore well yeah and so she
was always I mean obviously hired time
into the mythical figure you know
nationally but specifically for us
I mean if stories you hear mean they
were like superhero stories over did you
think it was a difficult read I will say
this that it felt like Toni Morrison to
me that I mean that in all the best ways
and I will say that the first paragraph
is also one full sentence and I had to
read that first sentence paragraph three
times before I figured out what was
actually happening the whole first
chapter is that kind of a dream sequence
yeah I guess through that and then it
and then it is a pumping plot-driven
here all the way by page 10 yeah you're
all the way in by page 10 Oakland
Tallahassee coats are not leaving we'll
continue our conversation next